hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a brand new candy crush jelly saga
gameplay preview there was a big update
last week in the soft launch which is
out and limited release and a lot of new
stuff and the game looks a lot more
complete so I thought I'd make a new
video just to show you how things look
and what to expect when this game comes
out worldwide so the main thing it's
called jelly saga it's it takes off from
the jam idea that we had in soda first
thing you notice is the candies have a
new look now that they didn't have in
our first gameplay preview it was sort
of just the same game engine so we saw
the same looking candies as we saw in
soda but now it's been updated and you
could see jam works the same way as it
always did so you make matches and
spread the jam nothing complicated here
it's the first level but you'll see
overall it has a really nice look to it
now like it's really coming along if you
go back and watch the first gameplay I
had you know this is a little bait this
is a big gum update now as far as just
how and so
I'm just gonna go ahead level off since
it's pretty easy but I'll show you some
of the other level types and what else
is new Susan done so a lot of people
have been asking about come out and you
know for the full release I've read some
articles there too
it'll be early next year so we're you
know we're maybe just about a month away
one of the things I noticed compared I
play all the games in sophomore it's
when I can and one thing I've noticed
that they really did speed up the did
speed up the development of this one
it's been getting it's been getting
complete completed a lot faster moving
ahead a lot faster so this is the this
is the first new game mode that's really
interesting this is the spread more jam
than the Queen so here we have we had we
have red jelly and she has been gelling
we're both trying to read more than the
other person so whenever I made a
special there I got an extra move but
typically it'll go back and forth
between you know one player goes and
then the other player goes like this you
know it's her turn so she's going to
take a move I get the move back so it's
pretty cool it's a heads-up kind of mode
and
she can do the same thing when she makes
special students and you know as far as
tips go for these its Queen it's pretty
good as far as like making them the
simplest madman most of the times if the
board lays out correctly for you you
know you have a wave you have a really
big advantage over her because she
doesn't she doesn't anticipate the move
that's gonna come afterwards really
unnoticed I just finished the last
there's a hundred and twenty levels in
the game right now I just finished them
all yesterday and this this type of that
the Queen isn't as bad as the the other
versus mode that I miss a little
decoration they can get frustrating at
times but you can see they're you know
it's she didn't do anything to like
really give me a big problem it's the
simplest level feels good so that's
that's
clean though this is the lot of verses
but this is the poplars and this is
similar to bears and candy crush so you
see make matches above them and then
they pop out and you have to collect
them based on how many there are there's
a couple big differences with this
though that the first is that well the
the biggest differences is that they can
actually move you can see I revealed one
there and it actually moved up on the
board so they don't stay static where
they're at but you can see like they're
there they have they come in different
sizes but generally they're about like
freely three lanes and set to find out
where they're at just like you would the
frosting and soda and then sort of taste
them down if they move away from you
Lucius marvelous so those are it so it's
pretty cool they were called critters in
the first one gentle issues so they have
a cuter look now can get frustrating at
times just like the Bears do but the
next level type it involves the it
involves them and it is actually what I
think is the most frustrating level type
and one I hope if we kind of smooth out
a little bit because some of the higher
levels towards the end of are really
tough
then they were really frustrating
let's see I'm looking for others you see
the different colors reversed
here we go so this is the final new
thing game-mode wise and this is cupcake
Karl right here so we have to bring home
more puffs lers and cupcake Karl it's
the same same concept except now we're
playing against each other like we did
with the Queen except when we don't have
the same goal and we have a little meter
up here
and whoever clutch the same deal when I
make specials and stun tomb so it's
always a good thing to do and I'm gonna
try to this is board's pretty wide open
so I'm gonna try to you could see as I
see this like kind of electricity on the
outside of the board you can see as you
the more of those you hit in a row it
sort of builds up a
it sort of builds up a an explosion
around the match that you make like it's
I'm just struggling to put it into words
here the what it does is like when you
make a regular match like you would
it'll it actually blows up some of the
area around it to just said you know
it's not a it's like a brand new match
it's just
it'll add add to it add to the effect
that it has that's the way so that's
kind of cool and this is a really simple
one but the the parts the the thing
about cupcake cargo makes it a lot
harder is that you're both trying to do
the same thing so there's this strategy
of like not setting him up like right
there to finish so that he can beat you
and you can see even in this really
early level it can be hard at times
because with the cascades and everything
else it's like you can't really you
can't really be sure like what's how
things gonna fall into place so it's
kind of frustrating another place I
found it frustrating and the high levels
was whenever the whenever he actually
doesn't make the smartest move like it's
good that they're not as good you know
the the the the opponents that you have
the Queen and cupcake are like you don't
want to be as good but at times it
frustrating because there's just some
obvious moves that need to happen in
order to open up the board say and like
I really really like you know like in a
board a lot of blockers you really need
to clear it out in order to save all the
pieces or whatever he won't make the
obvious move and it's just it can be
kind of maddening at times like when
you're really trying to move long so I I
just want to point out one other thing
here I just picked a random board that
this also they also added a new booster
this came two updates ago and it's a
lollipop
color bomb which is pretty cool it'll
take out all of the pieces of the same
color so you know if I click on the blue
it explodes all the blue and you can see
it's spread jam to them as well didn't
take away a move so that's a pretty
powerful booster you know I mean so the
question I have for you guys that you
can ask them you can put weigh in on the
comments would you like to see this
booster go in their other games like
soda because I think it's I think it's
pretty interesting and I think it would
come in handy in a lot of spots so
that'll break letter wrap it up for now
like I said they have added a bunch of
levels
we went from 80 that it was kind of
sitting at for a long time all the way
to 120 I played through them all and
beat them all without boosters right now
there was some times whenever some of
them were hard before like maybe
impossible the only level 63 and stuff
so it seems pretty polished really cool
looking map the way they disclosed
and found to be a fun title that
everyone's gonna have fun playing so
let's hope that it comes out soon leave
any questions or comments that you have
please like the video if you found it
helpful and let me know if you have any
questions in the comments subscribe to
my channel to get all the latest updates
like this and we'll talk to you soon
thanks